ou c'est le terme japonais pour désigner
le fan le grand
fan voir un maniaque quand Sébastien jar
a 25 ans regarde la télé c'est pour
s'évader avec une de ces 200 cassettes
d'animé japonais entendez par là des
dessins
animés quand il chante c'est en japonais
sur les musiques des mêmes animés et
quand il étudie c'est la langue
japonaise pour mieux comprendre
scén cé moins
une les Japonais font des dessins animés
pour tout style pour tout pour toute
catégorie d'âge quand j'étais j'étais
enfant j'ai fait un rêve qui se répétait
je rêvais que j'étais comme une sorte de
de petit
sauvage devant une grande montagne et
c'était le monfouji et j'en ai dédu que
j'étais un j'avais été un enfant
japonais dans une vie
antérieure